mask or no mask that's the question many
people have when they head out in public
today thanks for joining us at six
i'm denise valdez good evening i'm brian
loftis the cdc allowing people who
are fully vaccinated they don't have to
wear it but businesses can still require
it if they choose
those businesses ditching that
requirement the copper keg in centennial
hills and that's where joe moeller is
live tonight with more on those changes
joe
yeah well there's definitely some
confusion over this new guidance for the
best piece of advice
is to maybe just have your mask with you
in your pocket or maybe your purse or
something like that take a live look we
are at the copper keg
here on deer springs and durango you
don't need to wear the mask if you are
vaccinated
in here so people are enjoying
themselves but not all places are
jumping on board with these changes just
yet
after wearing face masks for over a year
there's so many emotions because people
have gotten used to it
some businesses are no longer requiring
mass that is if you are vaccinated
suzanne van buren is a bartender at the
copper keg we can't say anything to them
or ask
anything about it so hopefully everybody
abides by the honor system
and that's as far as we can go the cdc
stating if you have been vaccinated for
at least two weeks you no longer need it
now it is up to businesses we're not
going to bombard them we're not going to
say hey you have to show proof
the oma cafe in sky canyon says if you
have your shots
dish the mask if you want it's their
choice if they want to
we definitely support that if they're
vaccinated and they don't want to we
support that too
keeping the mask handy may be a good
idea some businesses are still requiring
you to have the mask on
well i was surprised that that happened
so quickly
some say despite the vaccine they still
feel better with a mask
it's nice to get back to normal but i
still have a little
still a little hesitant to just be
completely without a mask
now back out here live you're taking
another look here inside the copper keg
people enjoying this a lot of people we
talked to said they
uh like not having to wear their mask
once again but other places are still
requiring it so it's important to keep
it handy uh grocery stores
you know smith grocers uh they are
requiring it but other places like gyms
like the ymca
for example uh you are don't have to
wear it there if you're vaccinated and
you are exercising so
it's just a good idea to have it with
you reporting live here in centennial
hills joe morgan great news now